it's obviously a huge week for the nba
this season
back on i know you're not going to be
there but i am curious have you had a
chance to speak with some of your
friends in the league
who are living this life in the bubble
what have they told you about that
i've pretty much heard the same thing
that everybody else had the food wasn't
great
uh but they're like you know they're
they're working towards it and
and um i think you know guys are just
excited to play basketball again
um and i'm excited to watch so i'm
trying not to
to like pester these guys too much
because i'm sure everybody wants to know
how the bubble is and they're asking the
same questions and they're also
trying to concentrate on on their season
for the most part i left guys alone but
you know the curiosity of me
has been there so i think though i think
they'll be fine
you know on a on a more serious note of
course a big topic surrounding the nba
right now is
will the players or will certain players
kneel during the national anthem what
are your thoughts on that
yeah i think however guys want to
express
their support i mean should be okay
i think one thing that basketball really
did um
because we saw it happen with football
first and our season started a little
later back
when this was sort of a bigger topic was
you know teams wanted to do something
together
and i think that's really powerful too
or not i mean not not putting down
anybody that
wants to do something on their own but i
think it's a really powerful thing you
know some teams are locked arms i
remember that so
you know i'm curious to see what guys
will do and and how that's uh going to
come together but i'm really proud
and i'm biased you know obviously as a
nba player i think the nba does a really
good job of
sort of leading that that charge and
um you know they've done a great job of
giving players a voice so
um you know i'm interested to see what
guys do if you were gonna be there this
week do you think you would take a knee
during the national anthem
honestly i'd probably we'd probably have
a team discussion about it um
and and whatever we decided as a team i
remember that being sort of how we did
it
a couple years ago i think like i said i
think that was really powerful i think
uh
it uh it gives the team
sort of a an idea and a direction that
we're going to go in and
um sort of helps ease that because like
you know everybody's having this same
conversation right now
um so i think uh you know coming
together as a group with your teammates
is a very powerful thing so that's
probably how we would have gone about it
as a team
navigating the world of health and
wellness can still feel like a maze
that's why i've spent the last year
interviewing an incredible group of
luminaries as a part of my new audible
original
the pursuit of healthiness one of the
busiest men in the world
you're launching a podcast the pursuit
of healthiness what inspired this
decision
i've always been very interested in
health and wellness like even as a kid
my mom was a very very healthy person
was always reading nutritionist books
i was a health and exercise science
major in college and then when i got to
the mba i sort of just always picked the
brains of
you know our trainers and doctors and
and whoever was sort of like leading
that for us
and those were always the most
interesting conversations this is what
i'm interested in i really love having
conversations about so i was like if i'm
going to have a podcast why not
interview people who i really want to
like find out some information from
and also i think it's just sort of a
daunting world in general
i think there can be a lot of
misinformation out there so hopefully
this sort of bridges that gap a little
bit and people it doesn't seem
so uh intimidating for some people after
listening to this
ultimately i hope hope that people walk
away a better version themselves
and who's your bucket list guest to have
on the show
that's a great question i think michelle
obama is in all her work and everything
health related there's there's tons of
people that are doing awesome stuff but
you know she's
she's she's the go you're blake griffin
i mean i have to imagine that's an easy
phone call
yeah we're working on